one of your best friends in this league
making his way over here right now tyra
matthew tyler matthew congratulations on
the win
a huge performance for this defense how
sweet was this victory was the sweetest
part about it well i think anytime you
can get a win in december that's what
it's all about obviously you know we
think we're a playoff team and i think
it's all about building momentum at the
right time getting that confidence at
the right time it's a long season but it
kind of shortens once you get to
december what was the defensive game
plan coming in tonight did the weather
play any factors no well really we just
didn't want to beat ourselves you know
we know that those guys going to come in
uh and really commit to running the
football
but on the back end we really just
didn't want to give give them anything
easy what was going through your mind in
that 20-play drive that 20-play drive
they get to fourth down you stop them
and they get no points out of it yeah i
mean that's what you want man
everything's not going to go your way
you know from series to series and i
think defensively it's all about weather
in the storm sometimes
and obviously you have to deal with
sudden changes but i thought we
weathered the storm for the most part
tonight what's it been like from your
perspective watching this defense really
come together on the fly this season
yeah man listen i think obviously we
didn't start the year the way we wanted
to
but i think through the course of
adversity you kind of come together you
start to believe in each other more
whether it be coaching whether it be
players and i think we're just at a
point right now where you know we
believe in the 12 13 14 guys that's
rotating in and out on defense and then
we believe in our coaches as well how
was how good was javonte williams at
that boy it's a load yeah
it's painful just to watch him on tape
yeah he's tough man uh you know i'm kind
of like the old head in the group right
now and i was on the sideline telling
everybody he kind of reminds me of
maurice jones drew man so he's going to
be a problem for us going forward but i
could see that team really you know
committing and really giving him the
ball a lot more how hard was it to
tackle him he's tough man i tell you
like he's like one of those bowling
balls man
you know he's hiding behind that line of
scrimmage and by the time you see him
it's too late you can't get low
because he's already running to the
ground so he'll be a great player in
this league how good is it to get clyde
edward to lair back going into the
playoffs i mean he's big man you know
that's why we drafted him in the first
round to to really be an impact player
for our offense to to be able to create
mismatches to be able to get five people
out you know and beat any coverage um so
just to see him continue to get better
and better uh continue to be a pro
that's what it's all about
i feel like sorensen just loves playing
on sunday night football talk us through
that pick six one time oh man it's
beautiful man it was actually an all-out
blitz and uh dan uh his guy actually
blocked so uh he did what any smart
player would do you know he found some
work and you know the ball found him and
he got a couple good blocks and you know
it's good to see him score man he took a
lot of heat early on in the year
but to see him to see him score to see
him make that play man that's what it's
all about talk you know
you've been a mentor for all these young
kind of cornerbacks and these safeties
juan thornhill had an interception to
their lives well i think for me it's all
about you know seeing that progression
seeing these guys grow whether it be in
the community doing charity events or
whether it be just coming to meetings
early you know i want to see these guys
continue to grow a lot of those guys
have been following me a lot of those
guys
so what you want which is a good thing
so um but a lot of these like i said
earlier man just being committed to each
other i think it makes sunday night
football thursday night football a whole
lot better that's right and tyron got a
little added responsibility at home now
as a dad how has that changed your life
nice man
i i enjoy it man that's probably one of
the one of the most important things
right there yeah yeah it's probably one
of the most important things in my life
man just being a dad and you know
obviously not having mine around growing
up um it kind of makes you appreciate
yours a lot more so um
just looking forward to it three kids
yes sir for you man congratulations
how about one last question for me with
patrick mahomes is he you know i had a
little bit of trouble throughout the
course of the season what advice have
you given him to battle through well
just continue to be himself you know i
don't think uh everything is going to go
our way you know obviously we put a lot
into this you know in the offseason
whether it be working out or training
trying to build chemistry yeah you know
with your teammates and it doesn't
always go to where you want it to go in
but what i like about him man he keeps
pushing he keeps pushing through he
never points fingers he always takes the
blame he always takes the heat
and i think that's ultimately that's
what you want you know from your start
player well in about three or four years
when you retire you'll be right here
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports